hey guys welcome to another HT go on a  tutorial but just a little video I'm  actually this is a response to a video i  just recently saw titled vista light and  i just want to show you guys with the  three gigs of ram on this particular  machine if i go to manager right now  pretty idling i have one web browser  open i'm using 1.4 gigabyte ram hmm yet  me in the comment sort of tell me how  much ram you guys are using one just  idling not using Frank windows vista if  you go to applications i'm obviously  using one can interpret and notepad  document and a browser and others using  i mean all these applications are what  I'm running right now Safari under  burden Firefox preloader in it and i'm  using surprising large amount of the  three gigs of ram on this particular  15-inch laptop so yeah just leave a  comment guys thanks